alex is in los angeles hi alex welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave it's an honor to talk to you i
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up so i'm just
looking for some general advice here on
starting an e-commerce business
specifically white labeling products on
amazon and i'll just give you a little
background on my situation
so i currently run an auto detailing
business
but i broke my foot and i luckily just
finished baby step three
and this month i'm able to get by
without dipping into my emergency fund
and still having a little bit of money
to invest in amazon
and i'm allocating exactly a thousand
dollars
to get this business going and i do have
good guidance around me i have some
mentors
therapists facebook group uh you know i
definitely have good guidance around me
but
really i'm just wondering if there's any
general advice you can lend me to
uh you know so i can have my best chance
at succeeding
so what is it um where did you discover
the idea of doing this
about a year ago i actually stumbled
across a youtube video that
it was marketing a software and uh
the guy that makes the software was you
know just talking about the amazon
experience and what it really entailed
and it really interested me so i've
actually
it wasn't just because i broke my foot i
wanted to get it started i've been
wanting to do this for a while
with that guy's software
yes so he sold you
a business idea
um well it's this so the software
is something that you you do the product
research and you do accounting and
it helps you run the business um but
really what sold me was you know him
talking about what
the you know just what white labeling
entails and
uh so uh yeah i mean the basically it
was it was kind of the culture
of this you know his company and the
software and
you know the the facebook group that i'm
involved in
also is a group of these people
that are you know they also use that
software too
but there's just you know different
amazon sellers on there and uh
so um but yeah i mean i can't really
pinpoint exactly
you know anything that sold me on it it
just sounded like uh it was just an
opportunity i got
excited about once you started
explaining it and uh you know in the
youtube video
okay well um
is white label labeling on amazon real
is drop shipping on ebay
real yes they're real there are real
ways to do that
um but more people make money doing what
he's doing than what you're talking
about doing
right um right yeah and so i worry about
how you got into this and what it's
really led you to
uh it's not to say the whole concept is
invalid
uh but uh
you know i i would not end up i would
not want to end up paying him more than
you are making and you're really going
to be close to that if you're not
careful so
uh and here's what's happening is you
you found a concept
and now you're backing into it and
really the only passion you have for
this is
making money yeah you've already paid
him more well
alex oh i'm sorry uh what'd you say
anthony you already paid him more
so actually so basically what i paid for
was
the subscription for the software and
if he sells a curriculum that
i had bought a year ago and you have
lifetime access to the curriculum that
teaches you the ins and outs like a to z
what it takes to do it and um so i
already i i already paid
a year ago for the curriculum and then
it's a yearly subscription for the
software
well here's the thing i i am not an
expert on
white labeling on amazon i mean we sell
a
ton of product uh on on
all kinds of web based things and
amazon's one of them
so uh our marketing team does a lot of
that we don't do any white label on
amazon today
uh we haven't we produce our own
products so we don't need to
but the uh but they're products we're
passionate about and so forth and
uh so so what i would
the only thing i can counsel you to do
is is this smells like a get rich quick
business in a box thing that somebody
has promised you a bunch of stuff and it
just scares me the way it feels
i'm not a hundred percent so to where
i'm ready to just slam my fist down the
table and go
you've been had uh but but i'm worried
about you
uh and so if i'm in your shoes based on
that
if i get that feeling and i'm in a
situation what do i do i get some more
information
yes about this and i'm not anthony i
don't know enough about the actual
subject to advise you
but what i can advise you is the life
and business acumen part of this is you
need some input from someone outside of
people dealing with this guy yeah you
need to find someone outside of this guy
i was hopeful when you said the facebook
group that wasn't his facebook group but
it's his face
yeah so you're not got anybody outside
of
this uh guy
and his influence that's telling you
that this can be done
and telling you where the holes are and
the upside is
and the downside is the pros and cons of
what you're looking at doing
so you need to get with some e-commerce
people that uh
that know more than i know yeah uh but
also are not
in his camp and that's before you give
him
another dime yeah absolutely so uh um
yeah we need to go make some money now
so uh
yeah so the i'll tell you what alex let
me tell you what this lines up with the
reason i'm
when i was your age um
i went to a weekend or to a one night
seminar on how to get rich in real
estate
and this guy it was 25 it wasn't free
and um he their main pitch at that
seminar was not
how to do real estate their main pitch
was that
everybody's doing it it can be done and
for three thousand dollars this weekend
at our boot camp
we will show you how to do it and then
when you went to the boot camp
i didn't go but i know the guy that was
running it years later
i got to know him and basically what he
sold was
when you went to the boot camp the next
thing they sold you was well get in our
subscribe to our thing and
when you find a property we will buy it
and we'll go in partners with you and uh
and but you have to cut us in and so it
just kept going on and going and going
and going in layers
instead of ever really just saying hey
i'm going to learn how to buy
foreclosure real estate and i'm going to
do it right which is actually what i
ended up doing
right uh aside from this but and the guy
got me started to his credit like this
guy could get you started alex
in e-commerce or white label uh with
amazon that are very real things buying
foreclosure real estate's a very real
thing
running it through that system where i
paid twenty five dollars to get to pay
three thousand dollars to get to bring
him in on all my deals
yeah that i find for him yeah
and he puts up the money ha ha um
which never really happened it never did
i never found anybody who ever did a
deal
wow i know lots of people went to the
boot camp and lots of people signed up
but i never found anybody who actually
got hit the guy to put money into it
and um you know and then later on in
nothing down real estate he went broke
like i did i went broke too
sorry both of us went from but you know
that you so
the thing is you just you need to get
something other than this guy's system
because this feels kind of like that
yeah i don't know if that makes sense or
not i'm not saying the guy's bad but it
just feels like that